did you know that some races in one
piece have natural Elemental abilities
like fire water or even electricity or
that buggy the clown here might be
related to a tribe of cannibals and I
bet you don't know that the Yono kaido
this venomous Jailer and even this evil
pirate right here might actually all be
part of a secret ancient race that has
been hiding for hundreds of chapters in
the story and so let's explain every
secret history and even crazy special
abilities for every single race in one
piece of course starting with the
massive men and women of the giant race
whose culture is actually based on noris
mythology now obviously we do know that
Giants are literally the tallest people
in the one piece World in fact the
smallest giant is an absurd 12 M tall
which is like stacking about seven
average people on top of each other and
yeah that's literally the smallest one
this race is truly massive with some of
the tallest Giants reaching height of
over 20 M tall and of course with
Incredible size comes also insane
natural power and we have even been told
that on average Giants are the strongest
fighters in the entire world which just
makes a lot of sense I mean would you
want this massive axe or a sword like
this coming down on you now one thing
that you might not know is that while
the Giants most well-known island is of
course elb they're actually Giants who
do come from all over the world which
leads us to the most mysterious thing
about the Giants which is that there
appear to be secret groups among them
that have even more special abilities
for example these are snowy Giants that
we once met in Punk Hazard that are
twice as tall as regular Giants and are
completely covered with fur there are
also Giant and fishermen hybrids which
don't even ask me how that one happened
but these people are called Waltons just
like this guy here who we actually met
during the long ring long long island
arc and then of course the the most
powerful Giants of them all are the
so-called Ancient Giants also sometimes
known as demon Giants and these guys
take it to a whole new level the only
two confirmed members of the ancient
giant so far are ORS who lived centuries
ago and was once called a continent
puller and the second one is his
descendant little Oris Junior who helped
free Ace during the battle at Marine
Fort now on top of their extra- large
size and strength these two do seem like
more Beast than person with their horns
and sharp fangs but the next race in one
piece is even more furry than that and
that's of course because the minks are a
tribe of humanlike animals who live on
the back of this massive elephant now
what might actually surprise you is that
there is a very clear split on what the
Mings look like depending on their
gender for example the males are
basically fullon animals who just walk
on two legs while the females tend to
look a lot more human with some added
animal features like fur and animal ears
which does seem like a little bit of fan
service but we're going to leave that
aside but despite some of their cute
appearances this race is extremely
powerful for two main reasons first
there are one of the only three known
races in the onepiece world who can
naturally control an elemental ability
and we will talk about the other two in
just a minute but the Mings can actually
use something called Electro which adds
electricity to all of their attacks
which in a world covered with water is
just stupidly powerful if you ask me but
then there is of course also their suong
transformation and wow I mean this is
usually both beautiful and terrifying at
the same time because when a mink looks
at a full moon their fur turns
completely white and they gain
unbelievable boosts in speed power and
endurance there's one downside though
because if a Ming doesn't learn how to
control this power and turn back into a
normal form then they can literally kill
themselves by going berserk for two long
and like most non-human Races they
actually have a pretty dark history as
well because at one point they had to
flee to the back of this giant elephant
where they didn't originate from which
if you ask me it was probably to escape
being wiped out by our next race here
and that's of course because there is no
race just like in the real world that is
as destructive in one piece as humans
only that of course in one piece there
is a quite huge variety of different
humans from the pretty average weak
human that kind of could exist in our
world as well all the way up to
monstrously powerful ones like big mom
who can wipe out an entire tribe of
Giants all on her own but despite their
very individual Powers we already know
that humans didn't always used to rule
the world in fact some of the other
truly overpowered races that we'll talk
about in just a few moments were once
considered gods but humans were likely
able to conquer the world thanks to
their advanced technology and scientific
achievements how over you probably
didn't ever realize that there are many
unique groups of humans scattered around
the world now of course there is
something like the Kuja tribe who are
the warrior women of Amazon Lily who
seem to have a natural ability to use
hockey plus they somehow only give birth
to women so no man for this tribe unless
you're Luffy of course now there are
also tons of other humans who have super
strange appearances such as the chestnut
on top of this guy's head the round
squishy noses of the can ballistic kumam
mate tribe who might actually be
relatives of buggy then there are also
these ape humans and the horned humans
like the emperor kaido this man
scientist the warden of imple down
mellin and this member of Blackbeard's
crew as well because even though all of
their horns kind of look different
depending on the person they could all
actually be descendants of Ancient
Giants which also had these massive
horns as well like no seriously I just
need to know if these are just like
random design choices by the author or
if there's actually some real deep lore
here and there's some giant ancestry
tree that explains all of these
interesting features here and now while
there are so many Mysteries surrounding
humans one of the most misunderstood
races are actually the fishmen and murl
and that's because these are actually
two separate races and obviously Oda
took inspiration from the mermaid myths
in our world to create his molk now you
may not have realized that he basically
reversed the idea to come up with the
fishmen as well in other words merul
have a fish lower body and human upper
body while fishmen have a human lower
body and a fish-like feature on their
upper bodies but even with these
differences they can both live in the
sea and they can also have kids together
so let's break down the differences a
little bit more here even Because the
actual fishmen all have gills and lungs
which means that they can actually live
both on land and underwat fishmen are
also naturally tend times stronger than
the average human and on top of that
they usually have some special
characteristics based on the type of
fish or sea creature that they represent
so take arlong here for example who is a
saw shark fisherman and one of his
special abilities is that he can
actually regrow his teeth immediately
you know kind of like how a shark has
many different rows of teeth that he can
kind of regrow to the front or take this
octopus fishermen who can squirt ink
just like an actual octopus but most
importantly maybe is that the fishermen
are the second major group after the
Mings with the ability to control an
element because using their fisherman
karate they can manipulate water into
bullets slashes Spears and much much
more like seriously this might be the
most criminally underused overpowered
ability in all of One Piece but let's
move on here because all of this is
quite separate from the merfolk which
includes Merm mates and Merman who are
naturally born with a fish-like tail now
the men will always have this tail but
but luckily the women can choose to
split their tail once they turn 30 so
they can walk on two legs if they choose
to and while they don't have as many
special abilities as fishmen they are
officially the fastest swimmers in the
ocean and they can communicate with
other fish in the sea as well and now
we're going to get a little bit weird
here because even though they are
completely different races merfolk and
fishermen can actually have kids in one
piece and this can produce a child that
is either merfolk or fisherman however
even that can compare to the weirdness
of this next race or I guess RAC says as
we discuss the long body part tribes
that there are in one piece and I'm of
course talking about the long arm long
leg and snake neck races which are
basically all what they sound like and
are surprisingly based on Ancient
Japanese creatures the long leg strip
have extra long legs like big mom's
daughter here the snake necks have
freakishly long necks but the long arm
tribe might take it one step further
because they have an entire extra elbow
in each of their arms which means that
they can actually bend their arm in
truly unnatural directions probably the
most famous of these in the story is of
course the musical pirate scratchman aoo
but there's actually one thing that I
bet you didn't know about these groups
because while they might not be as
important as some other races the long
arm tribe and the longle tribes here
have actually been fighting a terrible
war that goes back all the way past to
the void Century which is just kind of C
crazy to think that they've been
fighting for longer than the world
government has been in power and
actually there's one more strange group
of people with extra long heads and
while we don't officially have a name
for them yet we'll just call them long
hat people for now who have a surprising
number of named characters for example
there is this Marine vice admiral this
scientist who sent automata to the moon
and this pointy-headed pirate and this
ninja leader here as well now what you
won't believe though is that the SK Sky
people are one of the most interesting
groups in the entire story and are
clearly based on angels and as we know
from The skypia Arc there are actually
three separate groups of Sky people
although they might have once been all
the same at some point and these three
are the skypan the Shand durans and the
birkens who have all differently shaped
wings and share a common background you
see during anel's cover story we
actually learned that all of the wing
people once used to live on the moon and
that they eventually had to flee down to
the planet because of a lack of
resources the Burkin and skypan settled
on the clouds and the shoran settled on
the island of G down on the sea and
while we don't really know a ton more
about any of their ancient histories we
do know that the shoran people were once
friends with the ancient Kingdom and
were even trusted with a poneglyph and
honestly though all three of these
groups of Sky people don't even have any
special abilities like they can't even
fly with their wings which is actually
kind of a major disappointment although
they do make very good use of their
natural resources located in the sky
such as the dials and the Sea Stone here
but speaking of special abilities the
One race with maybe the most overpowered
ability in the entire story is actually
the three ey tribe which may have been
inspired by ancient Hindu and Tao
beliefs now just like another extremely
important tribe that we'll discuss in
just a moment we only know one confirmed
member of the three ey tribe that's
still alive and that's of course big
mom's daughter pudding here who is a
halfblood member of this very mysterious
tribe which I guess means that there has
to be at least one more out there
somewhere like her father or something
now unfortunately enough though we don't
know much about them except that they
have the insane ability to awaken the
voice of all things which if you don't
remember this ability allows anyone to
essentially understand the basics of any
spoken or written communication like
when Luffy could vaguely understand what
was being being set by these massive sea
Kings and exactly because this is such
an important ability I certainly believe
that pudding or at least another member
of her tribe will be playing a major
role in the story at the end but now
from one of the most important races
let's shift to what is honestly one of
my personal favorite races in one piece
which are the dwarfs here or based on
real world Scandinavian mythology and
man like these tiny creatures are simply
incredible because despite their size
they actually extremely powerful what do
I mean by that well an average dwarf is
actually able to easily destroy an
entire building plus with their small
size they are experts at sneaking around
and remaining unseen and they are
incredibly talented at growing natural
things like plants however despite all
the positives the dwarfs or more
specifically the dwarfs that we met in
Dr Rosa hav't truly dark past as well
because just like many of the other
non-human Races they were once forced
into slavery for for hundreds of years
by humans luckily they were freed at
some point but still if we've learned
anything so far it's that humans can be
pretty awful in one piece as well now
what you may not know about these though
is that there might actually be an
entirely separate tribe of dwarves
because back in big Mom's library where
she collects weird things we actually
saw this tiny creature pinned inside a
book which is called a kinoole and while
we don't know anything else about it its
small size May mean that it's related to
the dwarfs as well and actually there's
also a bit of a pun here in the Japanese
name because kinoo translates to
mushroom while beo means human so the
name is just literally mushroom human
but now prepare yourself for this next
race because they are probably the most
individually powerful in the entire
world and I'm talking of course about
the lunarian tribe who were first
introduced during the battle at wano and
this tribe has a lot of symbolism and
history relating to the Moon I mean
their name literally means Moon people
but they are also associated with the
highest ranking Christian Angels
mentioned in the bible as well and while
still there is very little known about
this tribe we met the only known last
survivor during the wano arc as well and
as you can see they have a very unique
appearance with stunning white hair
enormous black wings and brown skin plus
you might have noticed that he has
literal Flames burning on his back
that's right they can l control fire but
what's extra special about these flames
on his back is that when they are
burning his durability shoots way up so
that even Zoro cannot damage him at all
however for some reason when these
Flames then go out he gets a speed boost
but his durability dropped so much that
zaro was finally able to defeat him
beyond that this lunarian can also
create flame blasts and even this fire
dragon but of course that's not even the
most important thing about the lunarians
because they they used to be considered
a tribe of literal Gods who used to live
on the red line somehow though this
tribe was nearly completely wiped out
and I can pretty much guarantee that it
was because of the world government who
tried to wipe them out after they took
control after the void century and kind
of build their empire on top of the red
line but what might be even more
shocking though is the insane idea that
demons might actually be another hidden
race in one piece hear me out have you
ever wondered why devil fruits are
actually called what they are well
wouldn't it make sense if there was
actually once an actual devil or demon
race that these fruits were named after
and with recent reveals in the manga we
have even more evidence that someone
like the world government secret Rua IMU
or maybe even the goo say might actually
be immortal Devils who have lived ever
since the void Century which would
definitely explain how many of them have
been able to rule the world for such a
long time but while this isn't conf
confirmed quite yet another secret race
was just revealed in the manga as well
with the introduction of a group called
the Buccaneers who in real life were
actually pirates that mostly sailed in
the Caribbean now apparently these
people are a hybrid race between humans
and Giants which gives them this
impressive size and strength but in
addition to that they are also one of
the only known groups of people who know
about the history of the legendary
figure NAA and of course this is the
name of Luffy's devil fruit but it was
all Al a historical person from the very
distant past and the fact that the
Buccaneers know a lot about NAA and
basically consider him a savior type
figure tells me that we will be learning
a lot more about this tribe and their
connection to na very soon and on top of
this what I think most of us can stop
thinking about is how strong is NAA
really was he a Buccaneer or was he just
some legendary powerful figure who freed
the world with his strength and if so
will Luffy's Awakening make him the most
powerful Young in the entire world well
if you want to find out everything about
Luffy as an emperor plus every single
mouthwatering secret about the other
past and current yonko you can watch the
entire breakdown of the yonko system
right here Shanks for watching and I'll
see you in the next one